moi j'étais d'élan tranche françois
bayrou suspense à peu près partout et
après ce qu'on en scoot on a commencé à
comprendre que ça valait point de la
faire des conneries ça leur apporte et
surtout rien du tout alors ça nous a
rapporté que des environs d'avoir
eu grâce à la salle j'ai cru comme un
autre commencez à comprendre ce que
c'était vraiment
ça dépend c'est s'amuser sans faire de
conneries
nous sommes à aubervilliers communes de
la région parisienne
au milieu de ces immeubles sans histoire
nous avons posé une caméra
c'est que nous avions entendu parler
d'une bande de jeunes qui se
réunissaient dans le quartier
une bande qu'est ce que c'est le mot lui
même n'est pas très sympathique
il n'inspire pas confiance
pour en savoir plus nous avons pris
contact avec certains d'entre
nous avons réussi à nous faire inviter
dans 7 cas nous et nos caméras
[Musique]
dix mois andré 7,7 câble cette salle
dans laquelle vous vous réunissez ça
fait combien de temps que vous l'avez
environ le 15 septembre enfin juste
après le mois d'août en dix ans 12
septembre on a commencé les savants et
sa venue comme un leader un joueur on
était on était sûr ici là dans le parc
d'enfants ont joué enfin on s'amusait
comme on pouvait pas ce que valait où tu
as fait c'est intéressant pas toujours
alors un jour on a eu l'idée on a
entendu parler qui avait la salle de
livres salle de gym de livres daté de
landau gardien nous a donné les clés
c'est quoi la selle de jeunes g7 câble
enfin c'était une salle il y avait les
gens au commencement qui avait fait
quelque chose d'essayer de faire une
salle de jeux ça n'avait pas marché
l'accès y est un jour vous avez appris
deux héros de cette série télé on a
demandé au gardien nous a donné les clés
on a commencéà à venir ici pour s'amuser
enfants il ya un peu tous les jeunes des
quartiers qui viennent on commence mon
nom c'était un petit roule sa bosse ça
se passait plutôt bien ou plutôt elle
il avait des désaccords des fois dans la
cité qu'est ce que ça veut dire des
déserts il y avait des bandes rivales et
avec deux petites bandes enfin deux
clans il ya aussi leurs deux clans et
les deux clans fans auront comme un pont
nhât les ont emmenés pour moi vous étiez
pas ensemble avons conservé dans les
dépenses qu'est ce qu'il
sait qu'en midi c'était le groupe kel à
l'école et une petit travail et qui
n'ont les ans les fréquentent répond
qu'on ne voyait
et pourquoi toi tu étais des groupes qui
travaillaient nuit et alors qu'est ce
que diront les fréquenter pas
voilà on est oui
mais non et ça donnait des petites
bagarres entre vous de d'là soir on
descendait laqué
grâce à qui tu oses on seront faits
après
et comment ça s'est arrangé
mais après on s'est rendu compte que
c'était mieux de venir ici quoi tu ne
resteras fait parce qu'on était tout en
caféine et vous avez décidé de l'unité
entre les deux clans ouais voilà on
dépensait tout le moins la boccia fait
tout
alors on a préféré venir ici qu'on
l'attend comment ça s'est passé comme
c'est devenu si vous êtes venu où
l'armée dit les gars qui nie la vague
heures enfin on a toi dis ça comme ça on
est venu
bon garder on ne sait rien quoi après
ils ont compris que on voulait pu dédier
des attentions en
train de travailler puis sont descendus
un jour comme ça vous aurait gardé
quelques-uns nous ont aidés on n'avait
pas confiance en eux on commence pas
vraiment vous à ceux ci les mêmes en
tout cas c est après mecquois l'apprend
ils sont commencé à venir on a pris
confiance en indiquant même voix ce
matin avec joe cocker confiance et pour
la peine de les laisser comme ça on n'a
pas le droit de laisser devant la salle
et pour tout le monde il a commencé à
porter ses activités enfin on commence à
danser à tour ils sont venus ils ont
commencé à prendre des poses aux
activités on les a laissés çà commence à
tourner comme ça et ils ont commencé à
prendre des postes dans les actifs sur
mon aura donné confiance et ça veut dire
quoi que vous avez organisé les actifs
là oui enfin on a essayé de 1 go pour le
barreau pour les disques pour les
boissons sis enfin pour tous pour les
sorties aussi
jean-pierre tuer le responsable du bar
toile depuis combien de mois depuis deux
mois on ça se passe bien non pas tout à
fait un c'est à dire
l'étude des bouteilles toit depuis
trente points les bouteilles vides toi
boudebbouz où ça c'est difficile à
organiser quoi là était en déficit ou
quoi la toile et sur la caisse je dois
des soins un pote moi j'y arrive pas
puis ce travail trop
et on tend galles voilà tous les côtés
et 10 mois
claude tu as eu aussi une responsabilité
voilà je tenais à la casse tu tenais la
caisse et tu la tiens plus non je
retiens vieux monsieur il y en a qui ont
permis de dire
je repartais de l'argent dans la caisse
puis comme c'est pour moi avant pour
plus j'ai largué tout son art est une
fille doit être plus de rien on ne
craint pas ce rapport permet une valeur
nationale chez moi c'est pas mon cas
penser des gangs je connais comme ça
quand les deux groupes se sont formés
dans des grandes le groupe qui s'est
permis de me dire ça
ta douche ouais ça m'a touché parce
qu'avant j'étais à ces voleurs d'un
contre la montre au cap alors j'aurais
pu en fait je pense que je serai comme
le soutient on jette à faire
at il dit je t'aime à l'heure ça veut
dire quoi tu étais délinquant peut quoi
ouais j'ai été de l'entrant je suis
passé aux cayes je suis fait pour ça peu
près partout et après je crois en ce
groupe on a commencé à comprendre que ça
valait point de la faire des conneries
ça leur apporte et surtout rien du tout
alors ça nous a rapporté que des
environnements voilà france on s'écoute
et qu'on a eu soin salle light tu veux
apporter beaucoup tu regrettes beaucoup
de choses
grâce à la salle rue grâce à la salle g
plus communs nous commencer à comprendre
que tu étais vraiment
ça dépend c'est s'amuser sentir connerie
j'ai vu que c'était ça et puis j'ai
commencé à discuter
une fois que vous aviez trouvé la salle
une fois que tu y étais avec les copains
là tu étais moins seul peut-être
heureusement seuls parce que j'étais
plus l'environné 60 et prend seul comme
armand rendront jamais rien à faire
chaud compromet dans la rue beaubrun qui
seront discutés furlan d'affaires guitar
heroes et croisés c'était
mais là j'ai retrouvé vraiment des
copains un certain niveau je me sens
mieux je me sens plus à 10 - française
une question que je me pose en regardant
comme ça comment ça serait tellement peu
de filles ici
et un pack c'est parce qu'ils ont peur
des sa maison verte descente pourquoi
ces gars qu'on ne connaît pas tout ça et
puis
les parents francis et pourquoi ils ont
réservé isation dégâts après cette
mauvaise nationale stellman normal parce
qu'on vient tout sans la salle il avait
mauvaise réputation quand il avait dû de
vente de règles oui parce qu'avant c'est
vrai que c'est dans les escaliers tous
alors
maintenant on a commencé à tousser
les patinoires alors maintenant les
filles commencent à descendre mais
comment satisfaire dès que vous arrivez
ici même on est descendu avec quoi le
champ sans
et comment ils agissent les kwasa ce
qu'ils sont à midi où est ce qu'ils
regardent encore ça va nous prendre
tellement content
les voisins dans l'ensemble ils sont
importants
l'autre fois on a une réunion la saur la
salle oui il ya des trois voisins qui
sont descendus ils avaient une pétition
dans l'âme
bah il dit si à trop de bruit et à trop
salée venu enfin il ya des grossistes en
france et à l'accès à la porte de la
cave il ya plus de joie nier les dix
mois ils ont raison ils ont paré pour la
poignée le corps aux raisons mais quand
il raconte qu on est à 100 dans la salle
ses droits
par exemple
enfin je vais arriver à 5h je rentre
je vais jusqu'à 7h30 oui après je mange
et je redescends l'air jusqu'à dix
heures tu es fou à minuit tous les jours
dans les baronnies vraiment est assez
fine 10 avec à salles curan plus facile
avant je sortais pas tellement
je crois que votre bonheur mais piqué à
la salle je rentre pas
mais pourquoi tu viens dans cette salle
tu es pas bien j'ai tout ça si je suis
bien mais là il ya tous les copains
c'est plus libre on peut parler
vous êtes nombreux chez toi
six enfants aillent chez toi
six enfants c'est aussi ça devrait
adopter aussi non non c'est assez grand
7e place pour vivre ici à huawei
[Musique]